the more i read about it the more i
investigated
the more i began to
realize that oh my god this is a huge
story
and it raised so many obvious questions
about culture
within these institutions
that i was just hooked
and i've been following it ever since
next to a landmark ruling on what's been
called the biggest tax heist ever
germany's top criminal court has
outlawed the controversial trading
practice known as comx
in short
it was
the world's biggest banks
brokerages
lawyers
accountants
hedge funds
coming together
over a decade to make billions and
billions of dollars
at the direct expense of taxpayers
across europe how much did you make from
com dividend trading how much did you
make
i think it was in the region of 700
million but um it's hard to put a figure
on it because of currency exchanges and
so on
sanjay shah
is basically a trader who has become the
poster boy
for that scandal it's hard to think of
too many other traders
in the history of the city
who have become so rich
in such a short space of time so at the
moment my my financial situation is
everything is frozen and
i'm allowed money to live on so the the
court in the uk has approved for me to
get paid every month living expenses and
also my legal fees and that's it
[Music]
so sanjay grew up in london in the 70s
and 80s
born london raised son of a doctor went
to medical school himself and dropped
out
he first started off working at merrill
lynch and then morgan stanley in the
back offices
i think he found it quite mundane he
very much was desperate to get on the
trading floor in the action
every morning i used to turn up to the
office and see
a row of sports cars parked outside and
i said to my boss who drives these cars
and he said the trade is due on the
fifth floor so i then decided that i
wanted to be one of those people and he
eventually landed on the trading floor
at credit suisse which was where he
first learned about dividend arbitrage
trading
he began to observe these
quite complex trades that exploited
taxes on dividends in a really lucrative
way now what he told us was
while he had done various kinds of
trades trying to profit from dividend
taxes up to that point the first time
you started doing crewmex trades was at
rabobank
on the eve of the financial crisis
around 2007 2008.
i think to understand kumix you kind of
have to go back
to london in the early 2000s
which was when traders in the city
began to figure out
how they could profit from something
that's called a withholding tax
these traders would make what is known
as withholding tax applications so they
would make
claims for tax refunds
multiple times on dividend taxes that
they only paid once analogies for this
that i've read are like it's the
equivalent of saying
you know me
you and a few other people were entitled
to
tax refunds because we all made a
donation to charity whereas in reality
it was just me who made that donation
but through a series of kind of very
complicated rapid transactions
we concealed or we made it very
difficult to tell exactly who it was
that made that donation on the date that
it was made so they hand out the tax
relief to a number of parties
that's what coolmex is
except that it doesn't take place with
charitable donations it takes place with
taxes on dividends
this is going to be one of the watershed
days in financial markets history the
day began with the bailout the prime
minister and the chancellor making it
clear that the financial system is so
important to our society that by saving
our banks we're saving ourselves
during the financial crisis however
rabobank decided to stop doing comex and
dividend tax kind of transactions so
sanjay was out of a job once again and
he decided in 2009 instead of finding
more work at a bank that he would set up
his own hedge fund
i didn't want to be someone who was
trying to get a job in a bank when no
banks were hiring i think he very much
wanted to reap more awards
um from the trading floor than what a
bank would allow so he set up his own
fund and called it solo capital partners
to reflect that desire to keep all the
profits for himself he started his fund
in 2009 with just half a million pounds
which really wasn't much at all but this
trading strategy was so profitable that
he amassed a fortune of several times
that
within three or four years he had turned
that into a personal fortune
of about 700 million dollars
and for about six years he lived the
high life he was making hundreds of
millions of pounds as were his employees
and he eventually went over to dubai
and he used that fortune to buy you know
a 32 foot yacht
he then traded that in for a 62-foot
yacht he bought property in hong kong he
bought property in london he bought
property in new york property in dubai
where he was now based he amassed this
global property portfolio and he amassed
this huge personal fortune i was advised
don't leave dubai because you will be
arrested and you'll be put in pre-trial
detention in 2016 after sanjay had made
hundreds of millions of dollars
solo capital partners shut down
around this time
investigations into comex trades were
swirling not just around sanjay and solo
but around the industry in general
the comex tax fraud scheme as has been
mentioned has cost eu countries
a reported 55 billion a huge sum of
money
through complex shared deals with no
economic purpose
other than to receive tax reimbursements
from the state and no actual tax being
paid
european citizens have to put to put it
bluntly been robbed kumex
it was always an aggressive
controversial trading strategy
but what people in the industry say is
that
sanjay shah and solo capital
went even further he's accused by
prosecutors of creating this network of
global entities including small u.s
pension funds and in one case a jewish
school in new york to claim refunds on
taxes on behalf of them as well
so in terms of the jewish school that
one really was audacious
the german prosecutors say he claimed to
represent this school which had
tax-exempt status because of their
religious status and this agreement
between germany and the us
so he claimed that they would buy german
shares and then his fund on behalf of
them would claim these refunds on those
taxes apparently without their knowledge
what german prosecutors allege
is that
sanjay used this small
jewish school and its tax-exempt status
to pull off
about 1.1 billion dollars of trades
this presumably delivers huge profits to
sanjay and his hedge fund solo capital
sanjay is now facing a legal assault on
multiple fronts okay
he's got
the danish
criminal charges which have been pressed
against him then more recently
prosecutors in hamburg germany have also
pressed criminal charges against sanjay
you feel that you you're being targeted
individually
yeah i feel i'm being targeted and one
of the reasons why is that right from
the beginning the danish authorities
accuse me of fraud being accused of
fraud means assets can be frozen by
prosecutors around the world it puts the
label to me which is unfair and after
five years nothing has been proven
there's two things there was the
legality of this and the morality of
this and for denmark they say that
sanjay masterminded a two billion dollar
fraud against their country and that's
nearly one percent of their gdp and so
the morality of this at a time when a
country is reeling from financial crisis
and there's mass unemployment
and state funding is being squeezed
across europe to defraud a small economy
like that out of 2 billion
dollars
is is really is really quite something
when we pushed him on the
i guess the morals of this
he said himself
that bankers and traders have no morals
the only thing that matters is whether
you make money legally or not all i was
doing he says was exploiting
that arbitrage the same way that traders
have done down through the decades
nothing new
well yeah the barn doors were open they
were told the bundles were open um
people were driving trucks into the barn
taking out truckloads of cash
for decades um and
they it's they're bad
it's it was an opportunity to be had i'm
not the only one who took that
opportunity there are many others
so it's really important to remember
that
even if sanjay is the the poster boy
of the comex scandal
he's a product of an industry he isn't
the industry by himself this was not a
rogue trading strategy that sanjay
dreamed up in in his you know in his
flight in london
this was a trading strategy that as
we've reported and as others have
reported was signed off at the highest
levels of some of the world's biggest
financial institutions
comex investigations have really taken
off in the past year germany now has
around a thousand suspects they've
convicted three former bankers they've
charged around a dozen others three
trials are currently underway
and it's really spread to some of the
biggest institutions in europe i don't
know where to start with deutsche bank
because as alex said they had a
downgrade at the end of last week there
are reports that garth ritchie and mr
jane the former ceo under investigation
now for this tax problem so for example
at deutsche bank 80 current and former
employees are being investigated
deutsche bank has specifically said that
it never directly participated as a
short seller or a buyer in comex stills
and it is cooperating with authorities
and in denmark where sanjay shah is
under investigation things have moved
more slowly he and others have now been
charged and but as far as we know
nothing has been done to try and
extradite them he remains in dubai where
it's very hard to extradite individuals
but this isn't um the end of the story
when it comes to comics investigations
really we really are right at the
beginning
i gotta tell you that when i'm i believe
i'm gonna be clear of this soon maybe in
a year or two when i am i will be back
in business and i will be pursuing these
types of traits
[Music]
you